Hello everybody and welcome back. Today
I'm excited to introduce the first
episode of the systems design 3.0
question series. While I spend a lot of
time on this channel talking about tiny
things, today we will just be talking
about tiny URL, not my Chad. So let's go
ahead and get into it. I'm trying out a
new format today. Please give me all the
feedback that you want in the comments
section. I've tried to incorporate
literally years of feedback that I've
gotten from a lot of people to make this
as clear and concise as possible. I
don't want to go overboard, but I will
explain things as we go. And please bear
with me. Let's get into it. For this
video, we're going to stick with the
minimum possible set of requirements for
a service like Tiny URL. In practice,
this means we need to support two
features. First, we need to be able to
have a client provide a URL and then
pass them back a short URL. These return
short URLs can be configured with an
expiration time after which point they
can be reused with another long URL.
Next, if another client provides us with
a given short URL, we need to be able to
redirect them to the original longer URL
that it maps to. Notably, we will not
cover a couple of other problems which
we will leave for subsequent videos. The
first is going to be the paste bin type
of functionality in which we allow users
to provide long text content to store as
opposed to URLs. The latter is actually
counting how many times that a given
short URL has been clicked. Fortunately,
for this problem, I've been able to find
some accurate usage metrics for the site
bit. Wikipedia and their official blog.
In their case, users create 600 million
short URLs per month, and the site
processes 10 billion clicks of their
short URLs per month. Converting these
metrics to get operation counts per
second, this means that we'd have 228
creations per second with 3,85
redirects per second. We've mentioned so
far that we want to be able to support
the creation of 600 million short URLs
per month. While these may be configured
with expiration dates, let's go above
and beyond and make sure that our URLs
are configured in a way such that we've
got plenty of capacity to make short
URLs. 600 million URLs per month comes
out to 7.2 2 billion per year, meaning
that over a 100 years, we might store
720 billion unique short URLs, assuming
no purging of expired URLs from our
storage. If we configure our short URLs
to use 8 characters from A to Z and 0 to
9, that leaves us with 36 characters to
the power of 8, which is almost 3
trillion. This seems more than
sufficient for our short URL suffixes.
At a high level, we need to maintain a
mapping between our long and short URLs.
This mapping gets updated over time as
users create new URLs and queried as
users provide a short URL to figure out
the associated longer one. While we
could keep a mapping like this
completely in memory with a hashmap,
that would mean that the data wouldn't
be very durable in the event of
component failures or restarts, given
we're only handling a few thousand
operations per second here. Using a
database in order to maintain this
mapping seems like a natural choice.
Let's think about an example schema here
since we'll need this in the following
section for some back of the envelope
capacity estimates in our schema. We'll
need the following fields. The suffix of
the short URL, the entire long URL, some
sort of user ID field for the creator
and an expiry time using millie since
epoch should suffice here. If we
estimate that a long URL is on average
50 characters, we can say that it takes
74 bytes per row of data. The breakdown
here is a bite per character, eight
characters in the short URL, 50 in the
long one, and eight bytes for the user
ID and the expiry time. Using our 74
bytes per row estimate in conjunction
with our maximum 720 billion rows, we
can see that at most we'd be storing 48
tab of data. The actual volume of
requests that we're handling here is not
super large. Databases can often handle
multiple thousands of reads per second,
especially if they're fairly simple, as
they are in this case. the right
operations become a bit less clear and
we'll cover them in more depth later in
this video. Is it possible to handle all
of these operations on a single beefy
machine? Honestly, maybe. That being
said, we'll discuss scaling this problem
out a bit because we'd certainly be
pushing the limits here. If we wanted to
use more commodity hardware, it feels
like a singledigit number of database
nodes should be able to do the trick.
Now, let's take a look into our design.
You can see that we've got a few
different components here. First, we
have a few application servers sitting
behind a load balancer which can
roundroin requests to them. Next, we've
got our distributed database which
contains the affformentioned URL
mappings table. In terms of APIs, it's
pretty simple. When creating a URL, we
go to the table and add an entry. When
we're looking to be directed, we simply
find the corresponding entry for our
short URL and issue an HTTP redirect to
send the user to the long URL. Note that
read operations on these tables are an
order of magnitude more common than
writes based on the calculations that we
did before. Hence, we want to optimize
for those. Finally, we've got a look
aside caching layer here which enables
us to avoid hotspots across our
different Postgress instances by
speeding up certain reads for popular
short URLs. The central piece of our
problem here is the key generation
service which is responsible for
maintaining mappings from short URL to
long URL. For now, we've opted to use a
standard Postgress relational database
here, which we'll cover more in depth in
the deep dive section of the video.
Because we want this to be distributed
across many database nodes, we can do so
by assigning each a contiguous range of
the short URL space. We can seed these
by creating a row for all possible short
URLs and an initial expiration time of
zero so that any new attempts to create
a short URL will succeed. The following
code represents the SQL statement that
our application might run in order to
generate a new short URL. Simply put, we
look for the first row that we can find
that has passed its expiration time and
claim it for ourselves. How do we ensure
that all of our database nodes have
balanced load? When creating a short
URL, our application servers can just
randomly select one of them. Retrieving
a URL should be pretty easy. All we need
to do is find the short URL in our
database and return the corresponding
long URL if it's present and not
expired. How do we know which database
node to reach out to? We should probably
keep a static mapping of the key ranges
per database node cached on our
application servers. We don't anticipate
this mapping changing, but in the deep
dive section, we can discuss what we
might do if we wanted to make our
service more adaptable. Creating an
index on our database table is a great
way to ensure that we maximize our query
performance in anticipation of common
query patterns. Since we know that
database reads will greatly outnumber
database writes, we probably want to
optimize for these. In our case, the
most common query is to find a
particular long URL for a known short
URL. This means that we should probably
create a database index based on the
short URL value. Internally, this means
that the database sorts the rows based
on the short URL so that we can use a
binary search to speed up our queries
that filter on this value. Postgress
uses single leader asynchronous
replication. For each shard, there is
one leader. All rights must go to the
leader and from there they are
propagated asynchronously over to the
replicas. Replicas serve the purpose of
making data durable as well as being
able to serve read requests and increase
the read throughput of our system. In
the event of a leader failure, Postgress
is able to promote one of the replicas
to take over as the new leader. Note
that because the leader is not waiting
for responses from its replicas before
accepting a right, it is possible that a
leader fails before all of its data has
been durably replicated. In this event,
we may lose some data when a replica is
promoted to be the new leader. At the
end of the day, this is just a URL
shortener, and data durability is best
efforts. While the majority of generated
URLs are probably only going to be
clicked a few times, a small number of
them may be used thousands or even
millions of times. For example, imagine
that Mr. Beast uses a short URL to allow
others to sign up for some giveaway.
There's no way for us to anticipate
which one of these short URLs are going
to receive tons of traffic in advance.
If we could, perhaps we could somehow
put them all on their own separate
database node. Since we can't, a better
alternative is to use a cache. Because
caches store data in memory, they can
often handle more than an order of
magnitude more requests than a typical
diskbased database. While the data here
isn't as durable, it doesn't matter much
since the database is our source of
truth. In our case, we can use a very
simple and easy to implement look aside
caching strategy in conjunction with
Reddus, an open-source memory based key
value store. When a request comes in, we
first check our cache for it. If it's
there, great. Otherwise, we fetch from
the database and have the application
server place the value in the cache.
Since we don't know in advance which
short URLs will be hot, using a simple
least recently used replacement policy
should help ensure that we maximize hit
rates while constraining how much memory
we need to use. If we make a very
handwavy estimate that 1% of keys are
responsible for 50% of the load in our
system, this would mean that we would
need around 480 GB of memory to serve
2,000 requests per second. Once again,
this could probably be handled by a
single beefy server. If we want a bit
more breathing room, we could instead
use a Reddus cluster, which helps do the
distribution and load balancing of keys
for us. In this case, Reddus could
choose a partition for each database row
based on taking a hash of its short URL
value so that they're evenly
distributed. We're now going to enter
our deep dive section. Do you need to
watch this to have a solid solution? I'd
say no. That being said, for engineers
who actually want to understand the
rationale behind the solution that I
provided, as well as be able to justify
their own in a systems design interview,
this section may be quite useful. In the
event that some of the terms that I'm
using aren't entirely familiar to you,
I'd highly recommend going through the
systems design concepts videos on this
channel. Recall our URL claiming code
from earlier in order to assign a short
URL to a particular client. Note that
databases are concurrent and as a result
each database node may have many
simultaneous requests to it in order to
claim a URL. Internally each query will
be looping through rows and locking the
first available one in order to update
it. If one query is grabbing the lock on
a row, another query will not be able to
move past that row until the first one
relinquishes the lock. Using skip locked
in Postgress is a way to simply jump
past any row that is actively locked and
only consider subsequent ones. Since we
don't care about which short URL we
claim, this is totally fine. Recall that
in our Postgress table, we are manually
performing random request routing from
our application servers to our database
nodes when claiming a URL. Instead, what
we could do is use some sort of database
that manages partitioning and routing
for us automatically. Performing manual
request routing seems silly as it
probably adds a considerable amount of
complexity to our application code. In
the event that we needed to rebalance
the key ranges that each database node
holds, things could become very complex.
Since we need to notify application
servers of the rebalance, there may be a
period of time where they're reaching
out to the wrong server to find
information for a given short URL. These
types of edge cases are not trivial to
deal with. Even though we're operating
under the assumption that we're never
rebalancing our key range, let's imagine
that this was possible. Why don't we use
some sort of extension for Postgress
that allows it to be horizontally scaled
so that we don't have to manage this
ourselves? What about a database that
not only performs request routing but
even automatically rebalances partitions
like Cockroach DB? While we could do
these things, there's some nuance to it
which depends on the implementation of
the request routing and the software
that we choose. Note that we're just
doing a select star limit one in the key
claiming query that I provided.
Depending on the implementation of the
request routing, we may always send our
requests to the first shard. If you look
at the APIs of many distributed
databases, very few of them provide a
way to explicitly select which node
you're sending a query to. We want to
spread the load of these URL creations
in order to avoid contention on the
database nodes. So, we need to be sure
that we're routing these requests
properly. It's probably much better to
use a database that performs request
routing for you, but you need to ensure
that your requests are actually being
evenly distributed to nodes. If we had
to build request routing ourselves in a
world where keys could be rebalanced,
that would be very tough. One example
where we could use existing software to
perform request routing is Citus, a
sharding extension for Postgress. Since
each shard itself is represented as a
Postgress table, you can create many
small shards relative to the number of
database nodes. This means that your
application server can request a list of
all the shard tables and then choose one
of them to query at random. Situs
delegates one postgress node as the
coordinator which knows where to route
the request for the shard table.
Therefore, you wouldn't have to
implement any manual routing in your
application. If we needed to
redistribute load between the Postgress
nodes, we can manually invoke Situs'
functionality to move a shard from one
worker to another without needing to
make any changes on our application
servers. In the past, I've covered an
approach to this problem in which we use
a hashing or randomized approach to
choose the short URL for a given long
URL. For databases where we can't
explicitly select a node at random to
run our URL claiming query on,
attempting to claim a random short URL
should spread the load evenly across
nodes in the cluster. That being said,
there is a world in which that long URL
has already been mapped, in which case
we'll have a conflict and we'll need to
find a new unclaimed short URL. Someone
may now comment that we can just hash
additional fields to reduce the chance
of conflict. Even if not very common,
conflicts are a possibility given a
limited number of short URLs and we'll
need to handle them in our application
logic. In this event, we could perform
probing by having our application
servers retry the request on the
lexographically next short URL. To me,
this just adds some additional code
complexity where we probably don't need
it. Though in reality, the chance of
hash collisions are super low.
Personally, I'd prefer to let the
database figure out which URL to pick
via one request, which we accomplish in
our key generation service, but I see
the case for both. When I choose a
database for these problems, I generally
try to consider two things. The first is
the index that they use, and the second
is how you'd typically perform
replication for them. In the case of
Postgress, that would be a B tree with
single leader asynchronous replication.
Why did we choose this?
Since we're looking for something read
optimized here, I felt that a B
treebased index made the most sense. Of
course, in practice, a good LSM
treebased database is still going to
serve reads faster than a bad B
treebased one. B trees read data by
traversing to a single location on disk.
On the contrary, LSM trees may search
for a piece of data in a mem table as
well as multiple SS table files on disk.
For what it's worth, the LSM treebased
index avoids grabbing locks when reading
those immutable files, leading to
potential performance benefits. In our
application, we're using single liter
asynchronous replication, in which case
we run the risk of losing some data on a
failover. At the end of the day, do we
really care? It's just a URL shortener.
Would we be better off using a system
with any other type of replication?
Leaderless replication as used in
Cassandra or Sila allows always
available writing by avoiding long
failovers of single leaders. If a
replica goes down, that's okay. Just
write to other ones. In our case, if one
of our Postgress leaders goes down for a
few seconds, we won't be able to write
to that key space until it falls over.
It really doesn't matter though. If a
leader goes down, we'll just write short
URLs to our other shards. In the
meantime, we can still perform reads
from its replicas as well. Again, this
is just a URL shortener. Temporary stale
reads from replicas are totally fine. We
don't need strong consistency.
We could also use multiler replication.
This enables low latency writers in
geographically diverse regions. Multiler
replication comes at the cost of write
conflicts when two users from different
regions concurrently claim the same
short URL. Dealing with resolving these
isn't worth the headache here. However,
we can still speed this up in a way that
supports clients from many different
regions. In our case, we could place a
subset of the Postgress shard leaders in
each region. Our application servers
could be biased to route URL creation
and fetch requests to their own region.
Cross region reads could be sped up by
placing readonly replicas in each region
with the caveat that they'll be a little
bit further behind the leader due to
extended physical distance. Note that
for the caching section, I went for the
simplest approach possible with using
Reddus and look aside caching.
Truthfully, I don't think the required
throughput for this tiny URL is enough
that we'd need anything crazier. That
being said, there are perhaps some
optimizations that we could make. Read
through caching would allow us to proxy
the database from the cache on a cache
miss, saving us an extra round trip to
populate the cache from our server. That
being said, we'd likely have to ditch
Reddus and implement this using our own
caching layer with an embedded caching
library so that it knows what queries to
send to the database. Welcome back,
everyone. I hope that you enjoyed this
video. Um, I'm going to imagine that if
I look at my YouTube analytics, probably
like 3% of you got here. Uh, so
congratulations on being Gigachads. Uh,
not going to pander and tell you to like
and subscribe. You do that if you want.
If I'm ugly, then uh, you probably don't
want to see my face much anymore. But I
do hope that this was a good
introduction to the new series that
we're building. Please leave me any
feedback or comments if there are ways
that I can improve. I am certainly going
to take them into account.